je suis ravie non non plus Daniel en
fait pourquoi elle n'est pas là ce soir
on lui a demandé de venir à pied de chez
elle
Daniel habite à 200 mètres
t'arrivera donc demain
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam c'est tout
simplement Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam question
pour vous ma chérie vous a coûté plus
cher le nouveau décor ou les nouveaux
chroniqueurs alors je vais vous dire vos
vêtements je vais vous dire
[Musique]
bon je vous le dis
les nouveaux chroniqueurs je leur ai
parlé
j'ai vu des chiffres circuler là sur
Pascal De La Tour-du-Pin mais les mecs
on a parlé
mais pour un million dans des PNP un
mélange tu fais tu fais tu fais trois
dynasties
ça veut dire ouais même ses enfants
c'est petits-enfants Césariens arrière
petit enfant voilà non pas du tout voilà
on va aller voir dans un instant déjà
comment ça va vous alors remonter
vacances a été impeccable super mais
merci
je fais une très bonne rentrée vraiment
non vraiment non vraiment tu envoies du
lourd
à côté de vous alors c'est quoi la
requête alors la requête lui il a été
donc euh
s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure j'ai dit que les anciens
parlent en même temps c'est inadmissible
qu'est-ce que je dois prendre des fruits
dans les fesses vous avez dit
ramenez-moi la corbeille
les gars je vous le dis donc comment ça
va toi là ça va super je suis content tu
dois aller chez le coiffeur tout à
l'heure bah oui mais c'était tu étais
déjà en fait comme par hasard et du coup
ils ont fermé dès que tu es parti ils
ont fait j'ai pas compris non mais tu
veux que je te dise toi c'est de la
longueur qu'il te faut
passer l'été avec lui
quand il arrive à la plage et ben je
peux vous dire que quand il est arrivé à
la plage et ben les gens réclamaient les
parasols
je vous jure à la plage il faut voir
Raymond à la plage ah non mais je vous
jure que c'est vrai attends et même dans
un camping tu as l'impression que tu
ailles sur une des plus belles bâches de
la plage de Sicile ah non mais c'est
toujours il était magnifique
mais sinon est-ce que tu as fait alors
moi j'adore j'ai fait des vacances au
Portugal en famille et après je suis
venu te rejoindre je suis reparti j'ai
fait plein d'aller-retours un coup je
venais j'ai explosé la famille cet été
j'ai vu j'ai fait Portugal avec eux
10 avec ta voiture
j'ai dit je vais
[Applaudissements]
lui dire à Saint-Jean-de-Luz est-ce que
tu peux me passer la voiture et de
Saint-Jean-de-Luz je me suis retrouvé à
Bilbao et de Bilbao
là il me dit il me dit ce pont il me dit
je prends ta voiture on dirait qu'il
allait faire un tour je l'ai pas revu
pendant 10 jours
et ce mec non mais sans déconnexion
merci merci pour la voiture je suis
parti ça ben moi je l'ai fait et puis et
puis qui fait ça
tu étais pas contente 10 jours après tu
devais aller à Paris la voiture je te la
ramène comme ça tu es tranquille tu as
ta voiture tu me dis oh génial tu me la
ramènes quand dans 10 jours
[Rires]
est-ce que tu t'y attendais pas non je
m'y attendais pas tu t'attendais plus
cette voiture tu pensais même plus même
[Applaudissements]
il a décidé de faire du sport cet été et
donc moi je joue je joue au paddle et
donc toute la journée déjà il faut
savoir le gars c'est le gars qui ouvre
le plus de canettes
de l'histoire de France je suis toute la
journée encore je suis dans une chaîne à
mon frère une chaleur de ouf et
j'entends toute la journée un gars
[Rires]
c'est super bon le like là le nouveau
truc la nouvelle limonade light tu
devrais essayer ouais mais je joue là tu
m'emmerdes et après qu'est-ce qu'il
faisait sans déconner c'était
extraordinaire il avait il se mettait en
tenue de footballeur
le problème c'est que maintenant il a un
physique de dirigeant
donc il est arrivé il est arrivé et il
courait dans le jardin avec un ballon
tout seul
et je l'entendais sauver Patrick
je vous jure il était devenu
complètement ouf et donc il court après
la balle tout seul ouais
basket d'équipe de France le ventre du
dirigeant le ventre du coach du juge je
touche et tous les matins je dirais là
je vais faire du sport mais d'abord je
vais prendre un petit déj petit déj il
me ballonnait donc du coup je ferai du
sport tout à l'heure faut deux heures
bon sauf que deux heures c'est l'heure
de manger
le steak de thon machin vient t'asseoir
c'était toujours en équipe de France
j'avais pas couru une minute et après
manger la sieste
la chaleur lui salue tape ici c'est
terminé 17h je me réveille et je gère la
faut peut-être aller courir tu vois il
me dit viens on va faire un tour en
ville on va chez le coiffeur donc
toujours en équipe de France
je vais changer je vais mettre le
maillot de Monaco
j'ai fait en fait j'ai fait que le
joueur de foot mais sans courir une
seule fois juste en ouvrant des canettes
ouais mais vous me foutez le cafard à
jouer trois heures de paddle en pleine
chaleur
il joue toute la journée il est 14h je
les entends taper dans la base c'est
merveille ils se mettent dans des états
s'insulter tout ça part en bagarre je
suis très bien on dirigeant
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va alors Valérie Benaim à
chaque fois que j'appelais cet été elle
était chez le coiffeur
de brushing du tout ah ouais d'accord
que j'ai laissé mes cheveux un peu en
tout cas
je confirme qu'elle touche donc donc
voilà je faisais des essais pour voir si
j'ai laissé les cheveux frisés pas
frisés ou bouclés c'est pas mal comme ça
aussi attention il faut qu'on en parle
je demande au téléspectateurs dites-nous
sur X parce que maintenant il faut dire
X à chaque fois que je dis x j'ai
l'impression que j'ai un gros mot mais
sans déconner c'est devenu ça va devenir
très compliqué moi j'arrive pas même
faut dire x donc sur X les chéris euh
réagissez à Valérie Benaim Valérie
Benaim
[Musique]
c'est la question que vous
faut pas tous sur X c'est tout de suite
donc c'est pour Valérie Benaim Valérie
moi je t'aime ah ouais je t'aime en tout
ah c'est vrai vous êtes très touffe vous
d'ailleurs je veux un film c'était
magnifique la touffe m'étouffe
avec Raymond une bombe vraiment une
bombe
je suis très contente là cette rentrée
je suis contente de te voir tu m'as
manqué
non j'ai pas été augmenté je suis
contente je suis là je suis bien ouais
on aurait dû la diminuer
ah oui maintenant je suis heureuse
vraiment c'est vrai vraiment ouais
vraiment continue à parler tranquille
là-bas tu vois que ça a pas changé il y
a des gars il parle mais tranquille ils
sont là-bas c'est la seule émission où
tu as des gars ouais non moi je suis
parti en Sardaigne avec des potes ça va
les gars allez-y en discuter hein ça va
Lionel
ça va super merci tu prends ton étoile
très bien merci
je suis content de les retrouver c'est
des cons
sur la tête de ma mère j'ai l'impression
je vais mettre je vais mettre 50 balles
sur le 23
j'ai l'impression qu'il y a des croupier
qui vont venir sans déconner c'est un
truc de fou j'adore j'adore Kelly
Vedovelli applaudissement pour
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
si vous voulez réagir si vous aussi vous
avez envie d'une touffe les chéris on va
accueillir dans un instant les deux
nouveaux on va cueillir de nouveau ici
également Gilbert ça va très bien merci
allez
vous vous demandez pas comment s'est
passé les vacances on va se retrouver
dans un instant Gilles ça m'a fait hyper
plaisir
alors j'ai perdu mes bagages on va se
retrouver dans un instant